For this reason,
people stay open for security,
serve active music or before the film
when it was necessary to test yesterday,
Enrique, maybe being in a prison,
Whitmill, Quick Hour, component of our
inventions, and the mister,
I know, is almost
cooler.
lilia pop
saxophone in a2 card with japan
roger del norte is artistic
ok wheeldon here I want to go for sure he
assured that he was going classic guantanamera
I'm going to have
ok
[Music]
everything
ah
with him
[Music]
no
to guantanamera
[Music]
and I'm an honest man where
do you think
it's from
[Music]
and
hello
look
[Music]
[Applause]
my verse is a light green
[Music]
say my verse is from oliver declared
the times
[Music]
[Applause]
or
[Music]
[Applause]
talavera
[Music]
with the poor of the earth  I want my
death
[Music]
[Applause  ]
dead
[Music]
[Applause]
e
[Music]
more
but
[Music]
[Applause]
give me
[Music]
nice forever
him
but
it in america and the spanish
scarlet knight previous define sell
passion  by william pierce
[Music]
by dilema
live
if the deep in your mind and so on philips
lite gaming
fin
me
[Music]
[Applause]
if you want me to turn from entertaining
dining room to chito of your talent and
response you can't ask for more
[  Music]
you have to do and don't leave me because
later you're going to regret it
[Music]
more
the little house you don't go to sleep
[Music]
when the street
e
[Music]
and if the girls are called from  courage
give me your
husband tonight I won't be able to sleep without
eating a lot of marijuana
[Music]
[Applause]
i
[Music]
ah
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
and
dawn
and  tonight you won't be able to sleep without
eating a marin brunette
[Music]
ah
a  little
in the middle
in iberoamerica not only
that but traveling drinking by breaking bad
by jane watson celebrating the spirit
big band people and imaging and coming
android and discouragement gentleman
[Music]
average
[Applause]
[Music]
more
ah
[Music]
no no
ah
to
[Music]
but same
no
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
[Music]
no
no no
and
[Music]
the good ones are
now not
going leading the  businessman
in half we are in space
i like them salute
from axel mondi serious
before mexican times
widget of look
6 whiskey
and the good
of thesis
slide
his game nature the decision which is
babalú by margarita the tail had moved
his country after locating his  papi form
touré starts with a single fact
[Music]
ah
no
[Music
] maybe I'll call my 17
[Music]
to put a line give me a piece of work
tomorrow
I'll go to the rite of love tooth
but there is no snow
[Music]
to money
a black
[Music]
and you can't not have another black
gave birth yesterday to someone who was
[Music]
well
and
[Music]
ah
and
[Music]
ah
california state and arizona then mexico
when sneijder
[Music]
no
e
[Music]
not now
[Music  ] I
would continue carmín
[Music]
richards
the guava tables it was good if
I aired on my mom and Guantanamera like here they ca
n't stand to see
[Music]
panamera
when I was
[Music]
look at
the truth
[Applause]
[Music]
but
ah
I'm the kidnapping of missing
stations
efe
the version is to walk
in the program the ràfol berwyn owes to the
ftc club platense
the interest of being celestial than the
penguin price  they will install
the road next week the comedian actor
seeks try to spin the
little giants
i'm sad
com
game
in freedom
in the city
at the wellness booth and workshop
thüringen commenting on alzheimer's
transforms life stories from having
our leader amber men and stopping the
story board scanner connectivity and
concept art to give you an idea in main
sprint about nir katz  half avis paul
pierce and destroy weapons to preserve of
the same brand
we are in being destinations production
absolutely of his life it was seen
necessary language identity was broken
waiting to
be possible opening of the presentation
of squeezing the water and defeated by
palm spirits but  stern that
garcía bernal turning big screen ex
manager in a cemetery is
truly like formentera they gave
spirit state and style and bobby
performance the baile carmen world
weening the field has been spent so much in
the old nursery forming life in the
tree first but they are much more
own truck explained
min
where anders
in that
díaz so much to welcome screamer in  of the
volcano flick of serving in the north
restriction of the film
[Music]
is because of the jazz themes
[Applause]
by sainz
business world and plasticizers in the
series friends will decide to sprint in
your own you have left then
fast version version of seris
de rest
basque institutions in california
within the ranking of celebration in the
first political force since before a
framework of american and fox i
live in
the castle
el agua de mar
style
efe
activists
wells
there are more artists
ander
on occasions
[Applause]
griffin juan bautista
but  welch
[Applause]
and andy schleck
at we have sandro the pension
[Applause]
I'm icaic cinematographic order in
turn well stable I'm already filming
opens fidel castro came
now
wow it's excellent for so many afternoons at
stansted the role of insisting on
developing that eventually destroy
builds intact verify ewald of
important the strawberry and chocolate that
eventually
no longer
expected
[Music  ]
the petista
walking in water radio production
in the name of rector claver and
verbal horn street is missing with posters of
arbequina paying them the bolivar goal of
tenerife that covers placed commercial
advertainment estradense revolution the one
to serve and mental publicity from 36 days
before by borders  brands and private
a month on live action network save
have a better mechanism your
webber win i opened them windows tenth bits of
art see winfrey coast guard perimeter
in your edition posters have action by
laura and truths film have suggested that
nothing being works bars underground and
the  bride holder phone before april
and sexual complementation
in politics
version let's
see if frei
and you more
this center
i
and
[Music]
very good
western is passion for surfing action
line and this way to be the stands
dress up union planet klaus mertes for
anders  to see and know latin america
price and highland in the term you are the
best without reflex films  spiritual
ion fall into the scope of action
trailer which is now werner countries to
eat turn onemi drummer
presenting the entities play is
asking affects the formula of néstor
kirchner
different and mental
from style and style
in short
movistar
yes yes
m
the sun
the  world organization for africa
why
[Music]
santi
wow
is this movistar power of caic master is presented
with time
efe
transit
carlos
freely and say black and white in
insurgents
yes it
is normal
feeling
entity
to graph this issue presents
performance and posters
the great space  for the expert of
rules of our production are typical
of smart texas tabular material alive in
pseudo golden years of our
production around cements exists
of metal and you know 10 andersen morrison
laws research and sweet jungle
you will see you see and come back from a
yushu chart
different
ar
of what
is really
with passion
/ spectacular strawberry and chocolate
lar
[Applause]
mirta ibarra
[Applause
] Life is
good, good evening, we have the privilege
of having you join us in this
special presentation on Calle de Francisco Colate
to the wife and muse of the great sinister
Tomás Gutiérrez
at the 'screening' of strawberry at the
collector hub of presence of the wife and
the news of film maker tomás gutiérrez
alea that is why
many know and in which it does not appear that
the backbone of the script in the
story the wolf the forest and the
new man is the extra step
and the man  new to newman the ice in
the step like the mustache and aptitude that
project with peter when he arrived
is the jasper project but i wanted to
start first by thanking you for
this invitation
and i also wanted to thank the
academy for the restoration that you are
doing of  the film of my husband
tomás gutiérrez alea endured he felt
meat sign caif for the restoration
car france vainaj appearance more than he has
goes out to a cuban fight against the
demons
various ios about diabetes in the face of their failures
and I hope I hope and I have high
hopes
jobs that the last scene which for me
is also a masterpiece of attention
from the super and my the death of a
bureaucrat a lousy master and opinion
bureaucrat software authors  they can be
restored seen more than every month web
thanks for all the effort you have
made and for this invitation to be with
you here presenting again
offer chocolate
to the the support and the presentation
attention to good how the project came about
good the project the story a good  day
in it titón presents it to him to
read it because he is going to send it
to the juan rulfo contest and he wants him to
read it and give him his opinion of brothers in the
game at it on the script to read with
page and manager and from there you  with your
youth center with a leadership test and he
answered and rolf or yes
and from the first moment
titón read it he told him this I want to make a
movie with this story in from the
first mamen p  iton asteroid story hills
world is in the giant to make a
mobile he spent two years working the script
is on twitter developing scripts
writing i think they are like 20
versions martín over twenty version
although he does not appear
in the titles as a
script collaborator and no bandages  I credited writing
yesterday without him he asked him not to appear and
keaton
from raiders in the narrow
tito there are no reports you know is that he
accepts no you continue includes tea
and in the middle of all this time
where so many versions were made well
suddenly I  he had done a previous movie to
get finish and saffron during
this time period
which was called adorable lies
bulaix yes and there was the character of
nancy underwear character name lancenet
this character that does not fit into
reality a character is ready for
reality and spends all the time  time trying
to commit suicide
but reality itself also really
prevents it verisign reality
whiskeys air france
in that movie  even before
almost at the end the character
closes the whole room and opens the gas
in that character film
the soft down interrupts and open
septic and that day the gas is missing in
Havana
and that they of mouths
[Laughter]
then in the middle of  all this
elaboration of the script they decided that it was
more interesting that there was this
love triangle from the
dramatic structural point of view of the
structure of the drama
software ag working love this version of
story realistic and you may want
to try and go for structure that of
another way would stay in this couple from
the gay and the communist or the whitest
original story was just another
heterosexual coming shelf that at
first I told titón that I did not
want to be the character where to see start
if totti tom decides to want to
character play because in the previous film
I had had an excellent review
and the character was very I liked a
lot
yes ha ha I
loved the critics with the character  character of the
film and I told him that these two
characters were very strong here and
my character was going to be relegated,
it's not important and he told me no, that
character is going to have a fundamental weight
in the film and you should do it, you don't
give characters  with a viking from youtube and
he convinced me that they compensate for
another factor that I didn't, which is
why I also didn't want to do it
because my husband already had cancer at that time
and was sick with laughter and don't
want to play this roll  and i'm
building time period just had cancer
old berger and i wanted to be
next to him not in the film it's the
same in turin text and mobile rehearsal
so juan carlos tabío the co-director
with tito and he said you can't do that to
tito andén de  co-director of ferns juan
carlos tabío all yuca no doubt your titón
you have to make the film me plus
your decision so I said well I
make the film if all my scenes
are at the end of the film to be
all  the time with him at the beginning of
the film yes, shouting for long moves
to the des gens works and I participated in
openings sochi teeth kobe bryant from
the very start yes and so it was andasol i
was jot in
addition to the wolf the forest the
new man of the character  nancy the film
has elements of two other bridges in
step one called alicia dances with
flora in my head don't tell her which
character from lance
story
influence of victory
within very important the strength of
the two characters in the story that serves
The base of the script is too much and in
particular the performance that he left I
asked him to give that credibility
to the character how was your participation
so that he improves but he could get to
do a casting for this film because
she
put some emission rights on it, you know the
crisis of the index  of challenge to sign
against this character was analyzed to
game of person but he ran for yuki and
green but production current if
we were doing a series  and on
television called beat the iss
i had already worked with georgia but
ria in another series on television also
the one with schuringa moments the
divisions in cuba on television colts
irala have left word pickford and
then i told him i want you
You are going to do the test for the
film that we are going to do
and I went and told the titón assistant
that I wanted him to do a test
for Jorge Perugorría in the event that they
attend fairs both plis test but it
happened the days passed and now  I was scared
and you weren't in the movie facebook go
better people so we met in
a place that had something like a
book launch and I told him
look titon this is the young man I
want to be the test for the
movie  when walsh matter pop
presentation and perugorría was presented wide
bars you lost mobile staff
so I told him look Jorge I don't know
what character you can do because you
have to do david  because
Diego is an older man
then suddenly Jorge does the test
for Diego one for David requested
people and not Jorge I consider the
character of David from John Mann peaks of
character or Diego issa comment and in
Jorge things and try study  of character of
diego and we are at home watching
tv titon is watching test d
watching all the tuba tests they
arrived from all the acts acts
straits on the part when jorge arrives he says he
is young but I like him as much as he looks
good but he was running sparta but  so
mission but we like the way you look is
gay so i told him but you can
take out his hair to make him balder
and that's how it was done in 2 athletic he took out his
hair so that when he lowers his head it
can be seen that he lacks hair
and i told him  and he puts some very
ugly glasses anti sep
making work they are verí ugly classes
and yes I think this is the person
because for you the most important thing in
the cinema was the look the eyes
inditex driver are víctor for he  r
husband it on the most important cinema
was the game of death
how was the process of making
working with the disease and with juan
carlos still hawas experience of
working consider granjas vents yúnes
landa director juan carlos tabío if the
first week that this rehearsal was not  he did
the rehearsal of some important scenes
and keaton underwent an operation
so he spent a week in the
hospital and juan carlos, who had already been
rehearsed, filmed and took him to the
hospital the scenes that had been
signed in the first weeks of destroyers
shows  titón heart one dragon
operation and then juan carlos you
tube shooting and bring the rise to tweet
ondas de hospital after this week
and titón went to the filming rehearsed
and everything was found and at two in the
afternoon three of us went home and  then
following attitude with set of
underground burriers had the trio o'clock and searched
and if there was anything left to do, juan
carlos agüere them verbally don juan carl  In the
future, yes, until it was
incorporated in its entirety, not old, it was
voted in full.
I mean that Juan Carlos is also not
there. Initially, I am going to
make some guests because he is sick
and he declined to attend something that we all
wondered when you worked in
the film was aware of the
issues it addressed and the way in which it was
made of the repercussion that happiness was going to have
on fashion and juan carlos and without
seeing the
same statism mir little gadget was a
very important film that titón
good almost all the films of
writer I don't think that in their entirety they
are very deep films that he spends a
lot of time preparing studying and
for him this film what he was going to
say with this film was very
important but I think that he
really exceeded all the expectations that
we had difficult for him.  not only not only
what was achieved in cuba with respect to the
change of mentality of the cuban but also what was
achieved by
the repercussion it had  international
fort eaton the same but the management server
imports packaging specialties one
he was very in conservative and want it
used in this movie go to shughour and
wanted to have the cuban people's
consider mental bucket and tiote cuban
under will james of mental tension and tea
and the  movie buen vivir in force
regarding sessions has not felt
outside apparatus
since 1956 when the academy created the
category of best foreign film
until it was nominated for that
chocolate 150 foreign films
were nominated for it 9
Latin American and precisely the ninth
was strawberry and chocolate the first
Cuban film to be and so far the
only one to be nominated for an Oscar.
Thank you,
what does that nomination mean to you
when you knew that you had
reached the goal of the film
having a journey that was how
we won the silver bear in Berlin in We
won at the  havana and suddenly the
nomination was already like the culmination no
because above all the tito said look no
i  It doesn't matter if I win it or not, the
important thing is to be nominated because that is
going to give the film such a long way
to be seen
internationally that that is the
important thing again, the award itself to
mobilize long life
and bigand agger  intensive berg in germany
the works inc
a festive tandem of oscar nomination
and four titón and you it is not important
that god carbap medicare in denomination
washington because i said you make the
movie
alone live
and you can be valued and could
be seen
internationally as it was  one
is stunned by seeing, for example,
Japanese people who say what a movie so many
people from such different cultures who
have appreciated in such a
profound way what the film says and have
understood that they
are different from the Japanese people for
example of girls live footage
andrés laying mobile  anti-seismic to
denomination in front of things that
have something that you mentioned cited some
interviews they expressed homosexuality  d
interviú will remain in force to end
down more sexual and yourself and whatsapp or
equal tolerant and opinion
I think that this is the deepest reading
that can be done of the
film because I think that one of
the things that makes the film  What is
current at this moment is that it talks
about tolerance because I believe that
at this moment there is great
intolerance in the world
religious intolerance intolerance
with immigrants intolerance with those who
think differently I believe that the world
has polarized into intolerance and I
I think that the film is the
deep reading that we can do because the
fight against homosexuality and
lesbianism really is a fight
that has been won. I think there are countries that have not, of course, there are countries that have not yet won that battle, I have talked a
lot to
myself  it seems the crisis bieber minister is
tolerant in things that the very
meaning and somerset and to see and contemplate
and special and to the times of today
this soft  ware intolerant religious inhalers
intolerance of a thousand
immigrants anda
there are events are contrasts
sexual
spence distinguishes operated
tolerate this from perm inning
so that battle is well won in
many
ghana
but it's a crittenton with 37
morrison homosexual singles beats bates
o veral and their our dealing with
religion and immigration reign attended more
than 20
if we make you enjoy the taste of
tolerance that you experienced today when you
found yourself in this place
and I cry again I don't know but
I can't suddenly distance myself when
I see the character I just  I keep on like I
'm doing it don't
send caster twenty five and the passion from
mobile to gent before typhus light crime
chicana field adverse taim strife
jas past
if you want to ask some eyes in
three surveys were daily
we look for cars
to your oil
if we talk about what  in many places it was
commented that the film was censored,
it was not that zombie state po  sadero the same
sensor incubates umbrellas no they did not set up a
theater with more than 2,000 seats what he
carlos márquez was the premiere and they
separated the people and he was like 10
minutes applauding
to end
later all the awards in all the
festivals where they were lost and when
they were  commercially premiered there were waves
that sometimes broke up to the door
to be able to enter sex except for
a southern festival cats and in a love say
stand dodge
5 g
or friendship hello I'm shaking every
time I saw David's suitcase I came from
Cuba with 16  years ago I remembered
school in the countryside I am now even the
backpack they used was the same as the one
we used there that many times I told
people here they have had merit
from gm micro ay del ay canfranc uva a
web sexting
remember the lost and just era  and
studies in cuba to cultural tutors
sin and annual in intention in these
subjects without sins me but I back in
chains worked without in in the long time it
is incredible p  because you took me
back to things that i hadn't seen
in a long time about cuba and in
this case i wanted to ask you a question
because i'm a filmmaker and really
what i'm trying to do now i want to
go to cuba i want to shoot a documentary
about my island  and I want you to give me your
opinion what restrictions there are for
people who are going to make movies here
from the US and Wolof TV from Cuba I already
found out nin
the film industry nahuel after work
airlines documentary film my line
on working day this restriction on the
possibility  somebody from this country
code and I think you can go and the same thing
you can contact
the film institute that with rtve commercial which is
from television but makes movies and
makes co-productions to be able to help you in
that sense you understand to be able to
orient yourself to be able  see if they make a
co-production or if it is only you who is
going to do it or assume it,
only cordic aid
and order soft institution withdrawals are indicated on that subject
before optimistic or gift that go
personal curve ones to go back and war
on duty also for change xunta post collaborate
and with television also well
no longer continue asking
like this because because they are
restrictions and you are American you can not
what you can is  buy or sell
a product made but do not
enforce american you can't buy by
name zelaya and embargo that this embargo
yes but you have a secure american passport
so it appears as americana here
and because of the embargo here it is not because there
is understand me
a  reference to the rehearsals many
may think that it is an apartment in the
center of havana like rehearsing and filming in
such a small place because the heat if it
is recorded already almost empty latina riial
location hawas de atacama baldo what they
consider hit office of cuba because
all that  building when when he enters
that you see the Cuban flag
avenge you all that is real there nothing was touched
the room was the only one that  he
managed to do Diego's and to
do mine it doesn't matter production
design everything west real from a
joke leasing jazztel was of
course rumor diego it was not difficult because it is
true that the location was very small
very small
with various complications and because  the space
to work around location west tourism
and interesting to say that this place
due to the fame that the movie gained
because all foreigners said where
strawberry and chocolate was signed now it is a
very famous restaurant called the
attic
because it had the queen of  spain eating
there microsoft we have the movie was a good
guy whoever is there the owner of the apartment is
a palate manager of individuals
the individual produced one we ordered the
fruit and coffee
from a
padrón and now I found out
when they signed the film this how
was that process having  note that
where the other demanding gave them freedom
to improvise an iron script of what
they did 20 scripts after 30
inversions works  hop from scripts by titon
open up ford improvisation and juana
silver street details what he removed was a
lot of acting detail you know
very well I remember that for example he would
stop when he knocks on the door
gattorno and he says I'm a friend of david's that
thing from first look look  From top to
bottom
delight in that kind of subtlety, no, but
in other ways and if one wanted to
contribute as an actor things like the flower, the
little thing about the Virgin, many things with
the Virgin, with the Saint, well, a little that
one contributes, one does not understand why one has
Seen as an example when the university
classmate camps to with France
Diego Dibós see and controlling movement and
actor
power without guards
and James but he was very open to the
movement that the actors had a
certain freedom to move and to
contribute things also
andy contributors because he said
that everything  that arose spontaneously if it
could be incorporated it
was much more real more truthful and
spontaneous
against real virtue edition of simo
network comet  If the film was
observed at the beginning the credits to
a proportion of Cuba with Spain and
Mexico in the case of Spain that is
because a Spanish firm financed
the script a part of the script that rewards
our city of Havana, not in the
case of Mexico
post-production issues so that you have an idea
the first show nothing is one of the
worst economic times for google the
so-called special period where almost
no electricity comes and it led us to
think about filming at the
churubusco studios to avoid blackouts and
also  the feeding of the technical team
of very good looks and difficulties in
convicting school of the special period
special events and a baby spain
finance of gration before scripts in
mexico the tweet of post-production
process areas of the cob energy and
light
should get commented mexico your city
South searched for indy animation in which the
same or even was edited on the
natural current defined television
because there was plant  to electric and that
will avoid the interruption by the wagons
spirits shot the west edited addiction
school of san antonio de los baños and with
leaving a lot of energy supply are light
electricity after information like
that difficulty 30 filming
or not
I don't remember now that there was  there have been
filming blackouts I don't remember blackouts
within the statement it doesn't seem like
we were lucky
I don't remember if I remember the blackouts at
night but we didn't sign much at
night almost everything was signed during the day
our film
tatis very old try well look at the
first one that the work of  11 He likes
that it can be seen
internationally by other
audiences with another culture and that they can
understand what that film is saying.
Not that is important to me, it is
also important to feel that my
already sick husband was able to make another
masterpiece and that for  It is also a
great satisfaction to me
when these two personal mobile phones are loved in Auriense, it
is an hour with three
posters.  rs and the joy to singer mirrors
of the end alex txikon cybers serious
or mobile bag
one hour teacher before dying a
masterpiece before die
so
thank you in chimoré we have opened your
presence and you that warm welcome
[Applause]
kim kye gwan welcome
my family welcomes
you  Quite
put
that gives me
the number in English
and a lot
[Laughter]
another hypothesis
sex sex
and seven fight